the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay now today we get to move on from
integral formulas and methods of
integration back to some geometry and
this is more or less going to lead into
the kinds of tools you'll be using in
multivariable calculus the first thing
that we're going to do today is discuss
arc lengths like all of the cumulative
sums that we've worked on this one has a
storyline and a picture associated to it
which involves dividing things up if you
have a roadway if you like and you have
mileage markers along the road like this
all the way up to say SN here then the
length along the road is this described
by this parameter S which is arc length
and if we look at a graph of this sort
of thing if this is the last point B and
this is the first point a then you can
think in terms of having points above x1
x2 x3 etc all right the same as we did
with Riemann sums and then the way that
we're going to approximate this is by
taking the straight lines between each
of these points now as get smaller and
smaller the straight line is going to be
fairly close to the curve and that's the
main idea so let me just depict one
little chunk of this which is like this
one straight line and here's the curved
surface there and the distance along the
curved surface is what I'm calling Delta
s the change in the the length between
so this would be s2 minus s1
if I depicted that one so this would be
Delta s is say s si - si - one some-some
increment there and then I can figure
out what the length of the orange
segment is because the horizontal
distance is Delta X and the vertical
distance is Delta Y and so the formula
is that the hypotenuse is Delta x
squared plus Delta Y squared square root
all right and Delta s is approximately
that so what we're saying is that Delta
s squared is approximately this all
right so this is the this is the
hypotenuse squared and it's very close
to the length of the curve and the whole
idea of calculus is that in in the
infinitesimal this is exactly correct
all right so that's what's going to
happen in the limit and that is the
basis for calculating arc length I'm
going to rewrite that formula on the
next board but I'm going to write it in
the more customary fashion we've done
this before a certain amount but I just
want to emphasize it here because this
handwriting is a little bit peculiar
this D s is really all one thing what I
really mean is to put the parentheses
around it it's one thing it's not D
times s it's D s it's one thing and we
square it but for whatever reason people
have gotten into the habit of omitting
the parentheses so you're just going to
have to live with that and realize that
this is not d of s squared or anything
like that and similarly this is a single
number this is a single number
infinitesimally
all right so that's just the way that
this idea here gets written in our
notation and this is the first time
we're dealing with squares of
infinitesimal x' so it's all just a
little different
but immediately the first thing we're
going to do is take the square root if I
take the square root that's the square
root of DX squared plus dy squared and
this is the form in which I always
remember this formula let's put it in
some brightly decorated form but there
are about four or five six other forms
that you'll derive from this which are
all mean the same thing
so this is as I say the way I remember
it but there are other ways of thinking
of it and let's just write a couple of
them down the first one is that you can
factor out the DX so that looks like
this one plus dy DX the quantity squared
and then I factored out the DX right so
this is a variant and this is the one
which actually we'll be using in
practice right now on our examples so
the conclusion is that the arc length
which if you like is this total SN minus
s 0 if you like is going to be equal to
the integral from A to B of the square
root of 1 plus dy DX squared DX
in practice it's also all off very often
written very informally as this the
integral DS so the change in live this
little variable s and this is what
you'll see in notationally in many
textbooks so that's one way of writing
in and of course the second way of
writing it which is really practically
the same thing is square root of 1 plus
F prime of x squared DX mixing in a
little bit of Newton's notation and this
is with y equals f of X all right so
these are the the this is the formula
for our Klein
and as I say I remember it this way but
you're going to have to derive various
variants of it and you'll have to use
some arithmetic to get to various
formulas and there will be more later
yeah question okay the question is is f
prime of x squared equal to f double
prime of X and the answer is no all
right now let's just see what it is so
for example if f of X is equal to x
squared which is an example which will
come up in a few minutes then F prime of
X is equal to 2x and F prime of x
squared is equal to 2 X the quantity
squared which is 4 x squared whereas f
double prime of X is equal to if I
differentiate this another time it's
equal to 2 all right
so they don't mean the same thing the
same thing over here you can see this
dy/dx this is the rate of change of Y
with respect to X the quantity squared
so in other words this thing is supposed
to mean the same as that yeah another
question
good question yeah so the question is
you got a little nervous because I left
out these limits and indeed I did that
on purpose because I didn't want to
specify what was going on really if you
wrote it in terms of des you'd have to
write it as starting at s zero and
ending at s n to be consistent with the
variable s but of course if you write it
in terms of another variable you put
that variable in so this is what we do
when we change variables right we have
many different choices for these limits
and this is the clue as to which
variable we use correct
s s 0 and s n are not the same thing as
a and B in fact this is xn and this is
x0 over here that's what a and B are but
s 0 and s n are mileage markers on the
road they're not the same thing as
keeping track of what's happening on the
x axis so when we measure arc length
remember its mileage along the along the
curved path all right so now I need to
give you some examples and and my first
example is going to be really basic but
it's I hope that it helps to give some
perspective here so I'm going to take
the example Y is equal to M times X
which is a linear function a straight
line and then Y prime would be M and so
D s is going to be the square root of 1
plus y prime squared DX which is the
square root of 1 plus M squared DX all
right and now the lengths say if we go
from I don't know let's say 0 to 10
let's say
of this of the graph is going to be the
integral from 0 to 10 of the square root
of 1 plus M squared DX which of course
is just 10 square root of 1 plus M
Squared not very surprising
right this is a constant it just factors
out and the integral from 0 to 10 of DX
is 10 let's just draw a picture of this
this is something which has slope M here
and it's going to 10 so this horizontal
is is 10 and the vertical is 10 times M
that's the those are the dimensions of
this and the Pythagorean theorem says
that the hypotenuse not surprisingly
let's draw it in here in orange to
remind ourselves that it was the same
type of orange that we had over there
this length here is the square root of
10 squared plus 10 M the quantity
squared that's the formula for the
hypotenuse and that's exactly the same
as this now that well I mean I know
maybe you're saying duh this is obvious
but the point that I'm trying to make is
is this if you can figure out these
formulas for linear functions calculus
house tells you how to do it for every
function the idea of calculus is that
this easy calculation here which you can
do without any calculus at all is and
they and all of the tools the notations
of differentials and limits and
integrals is going to make you be able
to do it for any curve because we can
break things up into these little
infinitesimal bits this is the whole
idea of all of the methods that we had
to set up integrals here so this is the
main point of these integrals
so let's do something slightly more
interesting our next example is going to
be the circle so y equals square root of
1 minus x squared all right that's the
if you like that's the graph of a
semicircle and maybe we'll will we'll
set it up here this way
so the semicircle goes around like this
and we'll start it here at x equals 0
and we'll go over to a and we'll take
this little piece of the circle so down
to here if you like alright so here's
the the portion of the circle that I'm
going to measure the length of now we
know that length it's called arc length
and I'm going to give it a name I'm
going to call it alpha here so alpha is
the arc length along the circle now
let's figure out what it is first in
order to do this I have to figure out
what Y prime is or if you like dy/dx now
that's a calculation that we've done a
number of times and I'm going to do it
slightly faster but you remember it
gives you a square root in the
denominator and then you have the
derivative of what's inside the square
root which is minus 2x but then there's
also a half because in disguise it's
really 1 minus x squared to the one-half
so we've done this calculation enough
times that I'm not going to carry it out
completely I want you to think about
what it is it turns out to be minus X up
here because the 1/2 and the 2 cancel
and now the thing that we have to
integrate is this arc length element as
its called
D s and that's going to be the square
root of 1 plus y prime squared DX and so
I'm going to have to carry out the
calculation some messy calculation here
which is that this is 1 plus the
quantity minus x over square root of 1
minus x squared squared so I have to
figure out what's under the square root
sign over here in order to carry out
this calculation now let's do that this
is 1 plus x squared over 1 minus x
squared that's what the this simplifies
to and then that's equal to over a
common denominator 1 minus x squared 1
minus x squared plus x squared and there
is a little bit of simplification now
because the two X Squared's cancel and
we get 1 over 1 plus sorry 1 minus x
squared all right so now I get to
finish off the calculation by actually
figuring out what the arc length is and
what is it well this alpha is equal to
the integral from 0 to a of DS well it's
going to be the square root of what I
have here right so this was the square
this was just what was underneath the
square root sign right this is 1 plus y
prime squared have to take the square
root of that so what I get here is DX
over the square root of 1 minus x
squared and now we recognize this this
the antiderivative of this is something
that we know this is the inverse sine
evaluated at 0 and a which is just
giving us the inverse sine of a because
the inverse sine of 0 is equal to 0 all
right so alpha is equal to the inverse
sine of a now that's a very fancy way of
saying that sine alpha is equal to a
that's equivalent statement here and
what's going on here
is something that's just a little deeper
than it looks which is this we've just
figured out a geometric interpretation
of what's going on here that is that we
went a distance alpha along this arc and
now remember that the radius here is the
radius is 1 right and this horizontal
distance here is a right this distance
here is a and so the geometric
interpretation of this is that this
angle it
alpha radians and sine alpha is equal to
a alright so this is consistent with our
definition previously our previous
geometric definition of radians but this
is really your first true definition of
radians we never actually people told
you that radians were the arc length
along this curve this is the first time
you're deriving it this is the first
time you're seeing it correctly done and
furthermore this is the first time
you're seeing a correct definition of
the sine function remember we had this
crazy way we defined the exponential
function then we had another way of
defining the log function is an integral
then we define the exponential in terms
of it well this is the same sort of
thing what's really happening here is
that if you want to know what radians
are you have to calculate this number if
you calculated this number then by
definition if sine is the thing whose
alpha radiant amount gives you a then it
must be that this is sine inverse of a
and so the first thing that gets defined
is the arc sine and the next thing that
gets defined is the sine afterwards
these are this is the this is the way
the foundational approach actually works
when you start from first principles
this arc length being one of the first
principles so now we have a solid
foundation for trig functions and this
is giving that connection
of course it's consistent with
everything you already knew so you don't
have to make any transitional thinking
here it's just that this is the first
time it's being done rigorously because
the U only now have arc length
all right so that's a those are examples
as I say that maybe you already know and
maybe we'll do one that we don't know
quite as well let's find the length of a
parabola this is example three that was
what I was suggesting we were going to
do earlier so this is the function y
equals x squared Y prime is 2x and so DS
is equal to the square root of one plus
the quantity two x squared DX and now I
can figure out what a piece of a
parabola is so I'll draw the piece of
parabola up to a let's say starting from
zero so that's the the chunk and then
it's arc length between zero and a of
this curve is the integral from zero to
a of square root of 1 plus 4x squared DX
okay now if you like this is the answer
to the question but people hate looking
at answers when they're integrals if
they can be evaluated so one of the
reasons why we went through all this
rigmarole of calculating these things is
to show you that we can actually
evaluate a bunch of these functions here
more explicitly it doesn't help a lot
but there is an explicit calculation of
this so remember how you would do this
well this is just a little bit of review
what we did in techniques of integration
the first step is what a substitution
it's a trig substitution and what is it
so x equals something tan theta I claim
that it's 1/2 tan and I'm going to call
it u because I'm going to use theta for
something else in a couple days okay so
this is this is the substitution okay
and then of course DX is equal to 1/2
secant squared u D u etcetera so what
happens if you do this I'll write down
the answer but I'm not going to carry
this out because every one of these is
horrendous but I think I worked it out
let's see if I'm lucky oh yeah
I think this is what it is it's 1/4
natural log of 2x plus square root of 1
plus 4x squared plus 1/2 x times square
root of 1 plus 4x squared all right
evaluated at a and 0 yeah so yeah I mean
you know
why did I make it a half because it
turns out that when you differentiate so
the question is why is there half there
if you differentiate it without the half
you get this term and it looks like it's
going to be just right but then if you
differentiate this one you get another
thing and it all mixes together and it
turns out that there's more so it turns
out that it's a half to differentiate it
in check okay so this is just an
incredibly long calculation it would
take fifteen minutes or something like
that but the point is you do know in
principle how to do these things yeah
oh he was talking about this half not
this crazy half here sorry
yeah okay so sorry about that thank you
for helping that this factor of 1/2 here
comes about because when you square X
you don't get tan squared when you
square 2x you got 4x squared and that
matches perfectly with this thing and
that's why you need this this factor
here all right yeah another question way
in the back
the question is when you do the
substitution doesn't the limit from zero
to a change and the answer is absolutely
yes the limits in terms of you are not
the same as the limits in terms of a but
if I then translate back to the X
variables which I've done here in this
bottom formula I x equals zero and x
equals a it goes back to those four in
the in the original variables so if I
write things in the original variables I
have the original limits if I use the U
variables I would have to change limits
but I'm not carrying out the integration
because I don't I don't want to so I
brought it back to the X formula other
questions okay so now we're ready to
launch into three space a little bit
here we're going to talk about surface
area
you're going to be doing a lot with
surface area in in multivariable
calculus it's one of the really fun
things and just remember when it gets
complicated that the simplest things are
the most important and the simple things
are if you can handle things for linear
functions you know all the rests so
there's going to be some complicated
stuff but it will really only involve
what's happening on planes so let's
start with surface area and the example
that I'd like to give this is the only
type of example that we'll have is the
surface of rotation and as long as we
have our parabola there we'll use that
one so we have y is equal to x squared
rotated around the x axis well so let's
take a look at what this looks like
it's the parabola which is going like
that and then it's being spun around the
x axis so it's some kind of shape like
this with little little circles it's
some kind of Trumpets shape right and
that's the the shape that we're now
again it's the surface it's just the
metal of the trumpet not the insides now
the principle for figuring out what the
formula for area is is not that
different from what we did for surfaces
of revolution but it just requires a
little bit of a thought and imagination
we have a little
monk of arc length along here and we're
going to spin that around this axis now
if this were a horizontal piece of arc
length then it would spin around just
like a shell it would just be a surface
all right but if it's tilted if it's
tilted then there's more surface area
proportional to the amount that it's
tilted all right so it's proportional to
the length of the segment that you spin
around so the total is going to be D s
that's one of the factors here maybe
I'll write that second that's one of the
dimensions and then the other dimension
is the circumference which is two pi in
this case Y all right so that's that's
the end of the calculation this is the
area element of surface area now when
you get to 1802 and maybe even before
that you'll also see some people
referring to this area element when it's
a curvy surface like this with a
notation deep uppercase s so it's a
little confusing because we have a
lowercase s here we're not going to use
it right now but the lowercase s is
usually arc length the upper case s is
usually surface area so also used for da
right the area element this is a curved
area element
all right so let's figure out this
example so in the example is equal to x
squared then the situation is we have
the surface area is equal to the
integral from I don't know 0 to a if
those are the limits that we wanted to
choose of 2 pi x squared right because Y
is x squared times the square root of 1
plus 4 x squared DX
alright remember we had this from our
previous example this was DS from
previous all right and this of course is
is is 2 pi Y now again the calculation
of this integral is kind of long and I'm
going to omit it but let me just point
out that it follows from the same
substitution namely x equals 1/2 tanh u
is going to work for this for this
integral it's kind of a mess there's a
tan squared here in this secant squared
there's another secant and so on so it's
one of these trig integrals that then
takes a while to do all right so that's
just is going to trail off into nothing
and the reason is that what's important
here is more the method and the set up
of the integrals the actual computation
in fact you could go to a program and
you could plug in something like this
and you would spit out an answer
immediately so really what we just want
is for you to have enough control to see
that it's an integral that's a
manageable one and also to know that if
you plugged it in you would get an
answer
right now when I actually do carry out a
calculation though what I want to do is
to do something that has a an answer
that you can remember and it's a nice
answer so that turns out to be the
example of the surface area of a sphere
so it's analogous to this two here and
maybe I should remember this result here
which was which was that the that the
arc length element was given by this
alright so we'll save that for a second
so we're going to do the surface area
now so if you like this is this is
another example the surface area of a
sphere this is a good example and when
as I say that has a really nice answer
so it's worth doing
all right so first of all I'm not going
to set it up quite the way I did in
example 2 instead I'm going to take the
general sphere because I'd like to watch
the dependence on the radius so here's
this is going to be the radius it's
going to be radius a and now if I carry
out the same calculations as before if
you think about it for a second you're
going to get this result and then the
rest of the arithmetic which is sitting
up there in the case a equals 1 will
give us that d s is equal to what well
maybe maybe I'll just carry it out
because that's always nice so we have 1
plus x squared over a squared minus x
squared right that's 1 plus y prime
squared and now I put this over a common
denominator I get a squared minus x
squared and I have in the numerator a
squared minus x squared plus x squared
so the same cancellation occurs but now
we get an a squared in the numerator all
right so now I can set up the D s and so
here's what happens the area of a
section of the sphere so let's see we're
going to get started some starting place
X 1 and ended some place X 2 so what
does that look like
here's the sphere and we're starting at
a place X 1 and we're ending into place
X 2 and we're taking more or less this
slice here if you like right the section
of the sphere so the area is going to
equal this and what is it going to be
well so I have here two pi x Y I'll
write it out just leave it as Y for now
and then I have D s alright so that's
always what the formula is when you're
revolving around the x axis and then
I'll plug in for those things so 2 pi
the formula for Y is square root a
squared minus x squared and the formula
for D s well it's the square root of
this times DX
so it's the square root of a squared
over a squared minus x squared DX all
right so this part is DS and this part
is y and now I claim we have a nice
cancellation that takes place square
root of a squared is a and then there's
another good cancellation as you can see
so what we get here is the integral from
x 1 to x 2 of 2 pi a DX which is about
the easiest integral you can imagine
it's just the integral of a constant so
it's 2 pi a times X 2 minus X 1
all right let's let's check this in a
couple of examples and then see what it
is saying geometrically a little bit so
what this is saying so
one special cases that you should always
check when you have a nice formula like
this at least but really with anything
in order to make sure that you've got
the right answer if you take for example
the Hemisphere so you take one half of
the sphere so that would be starting it
at 0 sorry and ending at a all right so
that's the integral from 0 to a so this
is the case x1 is equal to Z
x2 is equal to a and what you're going
to get is a hemisphere and the area is
two pi a times a or in other words two
PI a squared all right and if you take
the whole sphere that's starting at x1
equals minus a and X 2 is equal to a
you're getting 2 pi a times a minus
minus a which is 4 PI a squared that's
the whole thing yeah question
the question is would it be possible to
rotate around the y axis and the the
answer is yes it's legal to rotate
around the y axis and there's if you use
vertical slices as we did here that as
well there's sort of tips of slices it's
a different idea but anyway it's using
DX as the integral of the variable of
integration so we're we're checking each
little piece each little strip of that
type if we use DX here we get this if
you did the same thing rotated the other
way and use dy as the variable you get
exactly the same answer and it would be
the same calculation because they're
parallel okay so you're yeah can you do
surface area with shells
well the shell shape is the the and the
short answer is not quite the shell
shape is is a is a is a is a vertical
shell which is itself already
three-dimensional and has a thickness so
this is just a matter of terminology
though this thickness is this DX when we
do this rotation here and then there are
two other dimensions if we have a curved
surface there's no other dimension left
to form a shell
but basically you can chop things up to
any into any bits that you can actually
measure you can figure out what the what
the area is that's that's the main point
all right now I said we were going to
we've just launched into
three-dimensional space and I and I want
to now move on to other space like
phenomena but we're going to do this so
this is also a preparation for for 1802
where you'll be doing this a tremendous
amount we're going to talk about now
about parametric equations really just
parametric curves now so you're going to
see this now and we're going to
interpret it a couple times we're going
to think about polar coordinates these
are all preparation for thinking in more
variables and thinking in a different
way than you you've been thinking before
but I want you to prepare your brain to
make a transition here this is the
beginning of the transition to two
multivariable thinking we're going to
consider curves like this which are
described with X being a function of T
and Y being a function of T and this
letter T is called the parameter in this
case you should think of it the easiest
way to think of it as a time and what
you have is what's called a trajectory
so this is also called a trajectory and
it's location let's say at time zero is
this location here X zero comma Y of
zero that's a point in the in the plane
and then over here for instance it may
be it's X of 1 Y of 1 and I drew arrows
along here to indicate that we're going
from this place over to that
place these are later times T equals one
is a later time than T equals zero
alright so that's just a very casual
it's just the way we use these notations
now let me give you the first example
which you which is X is equal to a
cosine T y is equal to a sine T and the
first thing to figure out is what kind
of curve this is and to do that we want
to figure out what equation it satisfies
in rectangular coordinates so to figure
out what curve this is we recognize that
if we Square and add so we add x squared
- y squared we're going to get something
very nice and clean we're going to get a
squared cosine squared T plus a squared
sorry it's not a cube that's a squared
sine squared t whoops yeah that's right
okay
which is just a squared times cosine
squared plus sine squared or in other
words a squared so lo and behold what we
have is a circle and we know what shape
this is now
and the other thing I'd like to keep
track of is which direction we're going
on the circle because there's more to
this parameter than just the shape
there's also where we are at what time
this would be think of it like the
trajectory of a planet so here I have to
do this by plotting the picture and
figuring out what happens so at t equals
0 we have X Y is equal to plug in here a
cosine 0 a sine 0 which is just a times
1 plus a times 0 so a zero and that's
here that's the point a comma zero we
know that it's the circle of radius a so
we know that the curve is going to go
around like this somehow so let's see
what happens at T equals PI over 2 so at
that point we have X Y is equal to a
cosine PI over 2 a sine PI over 2 which
is 0 a because sine of PI over 2 is 1 so
that's up here so this is what happens
at T equals 0 this is what happens at T
equals PI over 2 and the trajectory
clearly goes this way in fact this turns
out to be T equals PI etc and it repeats
at T equals 2 pi all right so the other
feature that we have which is a
qualitative feature is that it's
counterclockwise
now the last little bit is going to be
the arc length keeping track of the arc
length and we'll do that next time